on August 21st
Noah died as a result of fentanyl
poisoning he was murdered by a drug
dealer selling counterfeit percocet
pills the pill he took contained eight
milligrams of Fentanyl
which is four times the lethal lethal
dose
that was Brandon Dunn recounting the
death of his 15 year old son at a house
hearing on the border issue Noah was one
of more than 70 000 Americans who died
from fentanyl last year a drug produced
largely in China then smuggled into the
United States over our open Southern
border
and how bad is this crisis well last
year the DEA seized 50.6 million
fentanyl-laced fake prescription pills
and more than 10 000 pounds of fentanyl
powder that's enough to kill more than
the U.S population here now is that
grieving father you just heard from
Brandon Don Brandon I started crying
when I saw your testimony as a parent uh
of almost now three teenagers and
everyone out there who judges anything
that happens in anyone else's family
i i i i i my heart breaks for you and I
applaud your courage in speaking out
because as we're looking at what's
happening across the world sometimes we
forget about what's happening right here
in our own country your message for the
country tonight
thank you for having me on Laura um
our message with the forever 15 project
is is a pretty basic one
um
it's to spread awareness of what's going
on in this country with fentanyl because
most people are unaware we were unaware
up until just maybe a month or so before
Noah's passing and a lot of people
think it can't happen to my kid I've got
a good kid you know they do the right
thing and we felt the same way Noah was
a good kid you know Noah was an athlete
he made good grades
um
you know he was he was
not we would never have expected that to
happen to us
um
and I came up here with just to spread
that message and to represent
the families that we deal with
since this happened whose message is is
pretty clear and that message is there's
a problem with this coming into the
country and oh we have an open border
Brandon Brandon yes your son your son is
gone is 15 years of age so many others
you know near near where where I live I
mean it seems like I'm reading about
something every other day
um
and we have an open border I don't care
what anyone says the border is
essentially open if you want to cross
into the country you can come in and
most people are staying
exactly and the cartels are taking
advantage of that
um we don't have the security that we
need at the southern border to prevent
not just this drug but all drugs from
coming into the country and
like I mentioned before the the families
that that we work with all you know said
go up there and tell them that there's a
problem at the border it's it's broken
and it needs to be fixed I want you to
respond on to something that was said by
a congresswoman at yesterday's hearing
what I find particularly pernicious is
the attempt to conflate the issues of
migrants seeking legal Asylum through
our legal processes with the very real
scourge of fentanyl trafficking
overwhelmingly comes through the ports
of entry in trucks and cargo ships not
on the backs of migrants
Brandon your response to that
well it's you know just another
diversion from the truth really I mean
despite how it's getting here it's
getting here and actually not much of
it's coming through cargo ships
almost all of it is coming in through
the southern border
well she's a sitting congresswoman and
apparently she's not aware of the fact
that we have a fentanyl problem at the
border
one of the other Witnesses
um also didn't seem to think there was a
problem which I find hard to believe
since his County had 64 deaths I believe
last year from fentanyl so
Brandon we thank you for your courage
and again our deepest sympathies to your
family all right thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else